[Music]
thank you
up here we're gonna drink unfortunately
what beer
um anything but Bud Light probably maybe
a Heineken Light
no Bud Light say no say no say no to
butt say no to Bud Light what is Bud
Light never heard of her
I'm here Corona
Coronas nope why not
uh because I hate drinking Bud Light No
More
this is a company once they get involved
politically then I don't want to support
that so you get two votes in this
country you get your first vote with
ballot second boater through wallet so
and I don't like Bud Light I'm
definitely not drinking Bud Light wait
we're not doing Bud Light I'm thinking
Miller right I'm thinking Miller right
I'm drinking bad light I'm fine without
I don't care no bud light's bye
hang a beer oh yeah I don't care no Bud
Light you know we're not drinking Bud
Light that's for sure thank you thank
you very much anything but Bud Light
yeah why not well because it's about
life yeah self-explanatory yeah why no
Bud Light
so Nationwide boycott that's why
freedom fighting Americans that's how we
do it I have some free
um controversy Bud Light that's in my
refrigerator and it's been there for
months and no one will drink it well I
uh I don't agree with the decision that
they're making you know I mean I mean
Miller Lite or Firestone 805 these days
I don't care who loves who don't Ram it
down my throat first light door's light
[Music]
down to deal with it
but honestly I don't drink food